LUCINDA SANDERS: Sit With
Me is based around
an iconic red chair.
And there's so many things that
a chair really embodies.
It's about sitting for the
future of technology.
It's about not standing for
anything less than women's
full participation
in computing.
And I hope this campaign
really helps
us understand that.
We need more women
in the workforce.
We need their creativity.
We need their skills.
ALAN McCONNELL: We've learned
over time that you can't build
great products if you don't have
a team that empathizes
with and understands
the audience that
the product is for.
LUCINDA SANDERS: We're doing
the Sit With Me campaign
because we want the world to
know that women are great
technical thinkers.
And it's time to do it now.
MATTHEW McTEE: I think the world
needs a campaign like
Sit With Me in order to ignite
a commitment towards really
driving more women into
careers in technology.
SHERYL SANDBERG: You know the
women who are dedicated in
computer science, who go into
math, who go into other
technical areas,
they're great.
And it starts with believing
they can do it.
COLLEEN BLAKE: As a mother, I
want to break the stereotype
to show my daughters that
hey, you can go to
that engineering class.
So it's part of telling that
story that's important for me.
LUCINDA SANDERS: We want women
helping to solve the problems
that the world faces.
That's what we hope
this campaign
provides a catalyst for.
JESSICA MURILLO: We sent out
an email a couple weeks ago
about our International Women's
Day event and wouldn't
it be a great idea to
have this red chair?
LEAH BRUNSON: The campaign is
getting lots of great buzz
here at Microsoft.
We had about 100 people here
to talk about the powerful
contributions of
women in tech.
They want to hear more.
They want to get involved.
We want you to have a Sit With
Me event or host a photo shoot
or use the chair as an
award program or
have a stealth campaign.
JESSICA MURILLO: Just do it.
It's not hard.
You can request a red chair.
You get some people together.
You take some pictures.
And you upload at the site.
It's just easy.
LEAH BRUNSON: Think about
the community.
How can we get the community
involved?
FEMALE VOICE: They're going to
take this iconic red chair
places that we could have
never imagined.
And that is the creativity
of this campaign.
ANDREW BOSWORTH: People who
aren't necessarily a part of
the process, that's a loss for
not just the rest of us who
don't get that perspective, but
also for them who don't
get to shape the future that
is going to come to exist.
COLLEEN BLAKE: This isn't
just a company
versus company issue.
It's a societal issue that
we're trying to change.
LUCINDA SANDERS: At the end of
the day, we'll know Sit With
Me's successful if we have
created a conversation around
the importance of women's
participation in computing.
And not just the [? monk's ?]
technologists, but everywhere.
MEGAN SMITH: [INAUDIBLE]
Thanks for coming on the eve
of Google I/O, which we're
very excited for.
It kicks off tomorrow morning.
And all of a sudden, there's
already been a set of events.
I want to welcome my
co-panelists up.
Come on up, you guys.
And we'll do some
quick intros.
We wanted to play the video
that you just saw, because
there's several red chairs
in the room.
And one of our partners, NCWIT,
which is the National
Center for Women and Information
Technology kind of
made this idea.
While these guys are coming
up, who has a
red chair in here?
There's one.
So you can see some of them.
So we encourage you, get a bunch
of red chairs into your
company and kind of make a
visual statement about having
more women in technology
in the room.
We thought it was a great
campaign and wanted to
highlight it as we kick
off this panel.
One of our goals, tonight, is to
give a chance to the women
and some of the men who've
joined us to hear--
of the women of I/O--
Google I/O--
hear from some of the
women at Google
who are amazing leaders.
And we want to talk
about two things.
One is technology and leadership
and building
incredible products and some of
the experiences we have had
and you guys have
had doing that.
And then also, we want to talk
about women in technology and
some of the experiences and some
of the challenges we all
face, and how-- you know,
things have gotten a lot
better and they're getting
better, but we still have a
ways to go.
So we'll kind of cover
both of those topics.
But let's start with
introductions.
So, Susan Wojcicki.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: Hi everyone.
Hello?
Is it working?
There we go.
All right.
Good evening.
It's great to see
everybody here.
Welcome.
And we're all looking forward
to I/O tomorrow.
So, I'm Susan Wojcicki.
I'm the Senior Vice President
responsible for our
advertising products and the
building and design of our
future advertising products.
We were working on building
all the great things that
we'll release over the
next coming years.
ANGELA LAI: If this works.
Can you hear me?
My name is Angela Lai.
I'm a vice president
of engineering.
I'm responsible for the Google
Wallet and the Payments team.
My team's responsible
for money that
flows through the company.
And it's great to be here.
Part of my team--
MODERATOR: Between Angela and
Susan, I think have basically
most of the--
SUSAN WOJCICKI: Susan and I
actually work together.
ANGELA LAI: And part of my
team, actually, is in San
Francisco here.
And I work out of the San
Francisco office.
ANNA PATTERSON: Hi, I'm
Anna Patterson.
I'm Director of Engineering
and Android.
I'm in Google Play.
I'm responsible for books and
search and recommendations.
GAYATRI RAJAN: I'm
Gayatri Rajan.
I'm the Director of Product
Management.
I used to work with Angela
on payments.
And I recently moved
to Google Offers.
MEGAN SMITH: And I'm
Megan Smith.
I am currently working on Google
X. I just shifted.
But for a long time, I led new
business development at
Google, which is the biz dev
team that helps these guys
when they are starting
new products.
And I also got to work out a lot
of fabulous acquisitions
with amazing teams that
we were lucky
to bring into Google.
So I guess one, as maybe sort
of a history-thinking
question, think about some of
your early experiences.
And we'd love to hear from you
guys a little bit of what were
some of the things that
prepared you the most,
different experiences that
prepared you most for what
you're doing now.
Just by way of sort of almost
examples for people, things
that you came across.
Anybody got any ideas there?
Early experiences.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I'll start.
I'm not sure, really, like,
any one thing prepared me.
I was lucky.
I joined Google when it was
a really small company.
I joined as the 16th employee.
MEGAN SMITH: Susan was
the Google landlord.
For people who don't know, Larry
and Sergey moved into
her garage.
So, that was her first
experience with them.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: So I
joined first as the
first marketing person.
And at the time, I
had very little
practical experiences marketing.
I had a degree.
I had an MBA.
So I can't really say there
was any one thing that
prepared me.
It was definitely working,
like I grew
as the company grew.
And I took on new challenges.
There was always new things that
I thought I wasn't really
sure I could do.
I had never really
done them before.
But each time I did them, I kept
building that skill set.
And so over the course
of the last--
it's been 13 years that
I've been at Google--
I've been able to build a
really great skill set.
So I will say my first job was
being a product manager at a
small little start-up.
And I really got the passion for
technology there and the
passion for building products.
And I learned by being at that
company that you needed to be
more than a technologist though,
that you also had to
have some business skills,
because the company went out
of business.
Even though I thought I
built a great product.
And so then I got interested
in also
building business skills.
ANGELA LAI: I'll piggyback
on that.
The Google culture, it's a
very supportive culture.
And we really believe in
lifetime learning.
And at the company, both
informal and formal, we have
classes to help people get
through things much like we go
through school.
And at the same time, as a
company, we always try to
shoot for really ambitious
projects.
And that's the way to stretch
ourselves, to
make ourselves learn.
And we always try different
things.
We're constantly trying
different things.
And the culture of experiment is
there and available for us.
And so for me, at Google, it's
a lifetime of learning, just
continue to better ourselves.
ANNA PATTERSON: I had a very
early conversation which I'm
sure Susan doesn't remember.
But I was pretty new at the
company, and I was saying--
I can't even remember
the project--
but I said that something
needed to be done.
And she said do it.
And so that kind of culture of
you see something and you
gather a team together and solve
a problem is definitely
one that I really value,
because it helps
us get stuff done.
GAYATRI RAJAN: So my
early experience--
it may not be early for you.
It was early for me.
I became a mother
in my early 20s.
And in many ways, that prepared
me for the career
that followed.
Because as a mother, I had to
learn-- one of the first
things you have to learn is to
give up control, to go with
the flow, to seek opportunities
where they may
arise, rather than having
a very strict plan.
It also taught me how to
multi-task, because I had to.
But I think, more importantly,
most importantly, it taught me
to really care about the
work that I was doing.
Because it matters.
It matters when you have
something else
you could do instead.
It really focuses you.
It makes you want to do
something even better than
what you might have
wanted to before.
And I think you need
that passion.
You need that flexibility.
And you need the ability
to just manage 100
things at once at Google.
And I think it's--
my children taught me how
to survive this place.
MEGAN SMITH: I think, we've been
working in the tech world
so much, that you know,
start-ups are like that.
They're just like
a free for all.
And it's just coming at you.
And you just have to try to
rise to the occasion.
So that's I think a pretty
good example.
There's a great book that
Alice Walker wrote.
It's called We Are the Ones
We've Been Waiting For.
And I think about the
things you guys
have said about Google.
It's our company.
And we just have to make it
what it's going to be.
And I think that if you're in
a start-up or in a larger
company, if you take ownership
like that, you see a lot of
benefits on that, not only for
what your company's going to
achieve, but also what you'll
get to be part of within that.
So I think that's good advice.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: So actually one
thing on that I think is
an interesting perspective is--
actually, when I first
joined Google, they said we're
going to hire you a boss.
Because I was, like, well,
I'm a marketing manager.
I just graduated.
I have my MBA.
And they said, well,
we're going to
hire a VP of Marketing.
And you'll report to that
VP of Marketing.
And I waited and I waited.
I waited for years for the VP
of Marketing until I learned
that I wasn't going to have a
person coming and telling me
what to do, that I just had to
figure out what are the right
things for us to do.
And we used to have
this motive,
like, act like an owner.
So that really indirectly
helped me.
Because I had no one to
go to for direction.
I had to figure it out.
And so it was very much a
sink or swim situation.
And so I do think that that
is like a really valuable
experience, where you need to
figure out yourself what are
the important things
to get done.
MEGAN SMITH: One of the things
that I did, in thinking a
little bit, we have an
extraordinary number of very
talented women throughout
Google and also in
leadership at Google.
We're really lucky that our
company values diversity and
talent inclusion.
And so we see that--
on this particular panel, I
asked these guys because
they're engineering and
product leaders.
And they've built amazing
products that are--
in the beginning, it was
millions of people.
Now, really, all of you have
built things that are
affecting billions of people.
And so, maybe to sort of stay
with tech into innovation.
How do you lead teams?
How do you come up
with early ideas?
How do you listen for ideas?
Can you talk a little bit about
experiences being on
this crazy rocketship and trying
to start new things and
then turn them into what
they have become?
ANGELA LAI: So things change in
the technical world very,
very quickly.
And there is our job,
and we deal with it.
And the way that--
speaking of engineering-- the
way that we do engineering
some 10 years ago is very
different than the
way that it is today.
And I will continue to vouch for
the really important part
of the group culture that
we continue to learn.
And we're not afraid
to change.
And that's part of
the culture.
And you need to continue
to spread that.
And every time this spirit of
pushing yourself beyond the
comfort zone--
what more can we do?
And look outside of our boundary
boxes, and figure out
can we try it and find
a way to try it?
And I think try not to say no,
and really trying to continue
to just sort of encourage
ourselves and continue to
encourage a team to think about
ways of looking at our
jobs differently.
And some of my colleagues would
say every year they
figure out how to blow up their
job and try it again.
I mean, really get out off the
mode of what you're doing day
to day, what seems to be
important to you today, and
try to get a new perspective.
And I think that constantly
putting ourselves in a new
zone or thinking that well, if I
weren't me, if I were Susan,
how would I do this?
If I were somebody else outside
of Google, how would
we look at this product?
And I think, trying to get a
different perspective all the
time is important.
MEGAN SMITH: Any others?
Talk about innovation, maybe.
One of the things that
was interesting me
was watching Susan.
You were on maternity leave
and we bought DoubleClick.
And we're just kind of wandering
around trying to
figure out what to do.
Susan was a big part of deciding
to do that, but then
she was gone when we were
doing integration.
We need Susan.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: It's because the
review took so long I was
able to have a baby
in between.
MEGAN SMITH: That's true.
It was amazing.
Just how do you--
all a sudden, thousands of
people join the company.
Would do you do?
How do you lead?
How do you help people put
something like that together?
SUSAN WOJCICKI: Yeah, I think
that the trick on innovation
and on managing teams and
figuring out the right sorts
of things to do is, first of
all, to figure out where
you're going--
and being able to say
this is the vision.
This is where we know we want
to be in two years or like
next year-- and then
working backwards.
And so if you have a vision,
everybody can rally around.
Everyone can start to
understand what's
important about it.
They can be motivated by it.
And then you can start figuring
out what are the
things that we need to
do to get there.
And so that I think is always
like the number
one thing to do.
And then I think the second
thing is just putting the
right people in place
and questioning.
There's always like
a challenge of--
teams think they can only do
this much, but then if you
inspire them or challenge them
or they have to, they somehow
manage to go a little
bit further or do it
a little bit better.
And there's always a challenge
of how do you get people to
really want to do that.
And I think a big part is
believing in that mission,
being excited, being compelled,
believing that it's
what they want to do.
GAYATRI RAJAN: And I think
another important side, even
as you get people rallied around
the objective and have
them think about new ideas to
excel, you have to be pretty
strict and very disciplined
about making sure that the
ideas that aren't helping that
vision, that they don't take
up air time and they don't
distract from the mission.
So that can often be the
harder part of the job,
because it's so much nicer
getting people forward.
It's harder sometimes
restraining.
But it has to be done.
So it's a balance.
But as Susan said, if you have
the right vision and if you
communicated it, people will
come up with the ideas.
It's almost an easy job for a
leader to just harvest that.
MEGAN SMITH: To crowd-source,
to harvest them.
Yeah, Anna, go ahead.
ANNA PATTERSON: I also try to
get people who actually really
believe in the vision and who
have a lot of passion about
contributing.
And with every project, there's
the exciting bits and
the boring this.
And so I try to actually give
each person an exciting bit
and a boring bit.
So they actually get the
boring bit done.
And they go on to the
exciting bit.
And the great thing about that
is then you can give them
another boring bit, right?
MEGAN SMITH: Good system.
We have a really great
OKR system--
Objective and Key Results.
And we really use
it with a lot of
discipline within the company.
I don't know if anyone wants to
say a sentence about sort
of how we do that, what we
do with the process.
It's a process we drive
ourselves crazy
with it, but we do.
ANGELA LAI: So those objectives
and results
actually speaks to how we just
[INAUDIBLE] ourselves.
One thing that is important,
like what Susan was saying,
having a vision is knowing
what you're
trying to drive to.
So the objective list, what
you're actually trying to get
to, not the task that you're
trying to do, not how you're
going to get there--
is actually
describe the actual objective.
And the key results, as a
result-driven company, is to
actually define what makes you
successful, what makes us
happy about-- what we think
whether we have
achieved the objective.
And so it's not about creating
a task list, even thought we
have to figure out which is
boring bits and which are the
exciting bits that eventually
we work on, but as a way to
get everybody to be empowered
to understand the goal and
objectives of what
every team, every
individual, the overall company--
at the different levels, we
define these objectives and
key results.
So people believe in what
they're doing, understand
where we're trying to drive to,
and then it really has the
part of responsibility and drive
towards the same place.
So it's a very empowering way
for the team to figure out how
to get in sync, and how to
prioritize [INAUDIBLE] what's
important and what we're
trying to get to.
And we can also look back at it,
and say well, we planned
that and sort of do a
retrospective on was that a
good set of things to measure
to start with.
And if we were measure our own
success by that, what do we
learn from it?
And that's how we continue to
innovate by reflecting upon
ourselves what we've actually
done periodically.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I was just going
to say I think that the
OKRs are sometimes like a really
good way of pushing us.
And so, one example was when
we worked on AdSense in the
very early days.
We were supposed to get the
online version of AdSense out.
And I think either Sergey
or Larry, they just
made up this date.
And they said you're going to
get it done by April 15.
And we were like really?
And magically--
we launched it like
two days late.
It was like April 17--
but that stake in the ground of
let me see if you guys can
get it done by this time really
motivated people and it
made us more efficient at
really getting that out.
MEGAN SMITH: Which is good.
And also having the habit of
setting stretch goals, as part
of the goals, and then letting
your team not achieve 100%,
but try to get to 80% and then
set more stretch goals.
FEMALE VOICE: I think it's also
been like a great system.
MEGAN SMITH: Maybe
turn a little bit
towards women in tech.
Somebody gave me these
interesting numbers.
One of them is that last year,
I think it's 54% of the 2011
Intel science for finalists
were in biochemistry.
And so you're seeing this rise
in bio, in chem, and sort of
the regular sciences.
I am on MIT Board, and
the undergraduates
are about half women.
And we're seeing about 80%
percent of the architecture
school is women--
and the sciences school, but
we're not seeing it in
computer science.
And so the stats that were
really interesting to me
recently going to the Computer
History Museum, which Susan
has recently joined
the board of.
I encourage you to go.
They have this amazing
Revolution exhibit that shows
the 2,000 years of computing
history.
But in the '80s, the computer
science balance was much more
even-- about 40% of the computer
scientists were
women, largely due to IBM
and other trends.
And now we're really
graduating--
I think, it's 14% of the women
graduating last year were in
computer science--
of people in computer
science were women.
And 18% if you take all
IT-type degrees.
So really, just very low
numbers, given the impact we
all have and the profound
impact of the tools that
computer science brings
in for the world.
I don't know if people
had comments and
thoughts about that.
I want to open up
for questions.
But we're doing a lot of things
with women at Google to
build community and recruiting
and those ideas, but maybe
talk about some of the programs
we have or other
thoughts you guys have.
What do you think's
going on there?
ANGELA LAI: So the
NCWIT boards--
the video that we produced has
the Sit With Me campaign that
Google sponsors.
The idea of the campaign
is to talk about it.
We don't know whether it's
scientifically proven or not.
But there are, we think, other
studies that we see that
there's some unintentional
bias, gender bias around
whether women are technical
or not.
And I don't know about
each one of you.
But the idea of the red chair
is just have that
conversation.
It has this icon that you can
get a chair from NCWIT.
And just have that conversation,
whether you have
a gender bias, on whether you
should be in technology or
not, whether people in
technology should be moving up
the ladder, become leaders
in technology.
It has had very good effect,
mostly to just generate the
conversation.
Because I think a lot of it
is unintentional bias.
And we don't really know why.
But once you notice it, then
the community will
self-correct for.
And that's the idea behind
the campaign.
GAYATRI RAJAN: You know the
products we build, they're
intended for men and women.
And the product that I'm
on, Google Offers--
I mean, women like shopping.
This is something that's--
MEGAN SMITH: And are responsible
for a lot of
shopping across the family.
GAYATRI RAJAN: A very
loyal bias.
It's clear that everything
we do, we're
doing for men and women.
Somewhere in the pipeline,
there's a perception that
technology is very male.
And I think what
we have to do--
and this is the responsibility
of everyone in the room who is
in technology--
is to tell the story of
what we do, in a way
that appeals to girls.
And I say girls, not women,
because by the time they're
women, it's too late.
So we have to find a
way to translate--
if they're not interested in
video games, find a way--
maybe it's a social game or a
game around philanthropy or
giving that appeals to them and
really find a way to tell
the story of technology in a way
that resonates with women.
I don't think we do that now.
ANNA PATTERSON: I think as a
career, it's very social.
And I think media
portrays it--
and a lot of people, their
stereotypes in other
industries think it's
a very loner thing.
And actually working in an
engineering team is a
remarkably together thing, like
rowing crew together.
I mean, it's really intense
social interactions and a lot
of teamwork.
And so I think women could
bring a lot to it.
And they bring a lot
to their teams.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: But I'm
always surprised
there aren't more women.
Because I think if you look at
technologies afield, it's such
a new field.
And there's so much
opportunity.
And to me, that means
that there isn't
really time to be biased.
If you have a great product, it
doesn't really matter who's
the person who's running
that product.
If you have a great company,
if you have a great idea,
there's lots of opportunity.
There's so much opportunity here
that women have that, I
think once they're in the
system, they're able to
achieve a lot.
But what the challenge is, and
actually you once told me this
great quote, like, there are
lots of-- what did you say?
Megan told me.
Basically you have to know that
opportunity is there.
If you get here and you get in
technology, then you have
those opportunities.
But if you don't even know those
opportunities are there,
you'll never actually
get there
MEGAN SMITH: We're all in a
group called Women at Goog--
in fact, there's 19 employee
resource groups at Google that
were created by the various
teams to interconnect us.
And actually, turns out there's
30,000 Googlers.
And I think there's 12,000 or
15,000 people on these lists.
So Women At is one that
we participate in.
And some of you guys are in the
Google Women Engineering.
Gayglers, VetNet, Black Googlers
Network, Hispanic
Googlers Network, Filipino
Googlers, Googler American
Indian Network-- just amazing
groups of people.
And so we were talking all about
this and how a lot of
people out of the world don't
know about the world we live
in and how exciting they are.
And so how do you tell people
especially, when we're often
in countries that are so highly
racially divided or
countries that are gender
divided, or--
sometimes, often for our
companies, we're hiring so
fast, we're like who knows
someone from this?
And so we just keep
perpetrating the talent circles.
And instead like, who
knows a woman?
Who knows someone from an
underrepresented group, in
addition to just asking
the question in
general, to get them in.
Because there's a wonderful
actual interview with three
African American CEOs here in
Silicon Valley, and they're
saying exactly this, which is,
if you can get here, it's a
meritocracy in many ways.
But finding out we're here, the
tech industry is here, is
an important thing
to make happen.
So one of the things that--
you mentioned media.
Gayatri organized a great event
last year, which was a
conference of the various
women leaders and folks
getting together.
And we were lucky to
have Geena Davis.
And I don't know if anyone wants
to mention some of her
findings, but she did an
extraordinary study of the
media that we all watch for
six-year-olds and under.
And so you were talking about
sort of what you see, like
this loner engineer
or the loner.
But actually the portrayal
of women is
the interesting there.
I think she told us that it's
two to three men or boys
on-screen to one girl
or women in
cartoons and various things.
She has a funny joke about
the film Nemo--
wonderful, one of my favorite
Pixar films.
But how many women or
girls in the ocean?
Yeah, there's one.
So, it's Dory.
I think there might be some
little girls on the swimming
fish school.
And mom gets killed of course.
But there's one.
So that's like really
happening in
the ocean, I guess.
So just that we grow up with
this image that Smurfette,
that the world is made of lots
of boys with one girl.
And so we imagine this.
And the one that was most
telling, Anna, to your point
is about jobs.
Its that 80%--
yeah, 80%--
what was the stat?--
are held--
ANNA PATTERSON: 80% of the jobs
in these cartoons were
held by men.
MEGAN SMITH: Right.
ANNA PATTERSON: Or 80% of the
jobs in shows targeted for the
under six-year-olds
were held by men.
MEGAN SMITH: So the boys
are learning that
men hold the jobs.
And these jobs, the girls are
learning that-- in fact, Geena
says boys will be boys and
girls will be boys.
You have To translate to be a
boy, to think about being a
scientist or an engineer or a
businessperson or a lawyer--
examples of people
who are not even
depicted in the 20% women.
OK.
We should open up to some
questions from you guys.
I think there's some
mics around.
I have a little bit of--
a couple questions people have
asked on the Google Moderator.
Is there a mic around
for these folks?
Or we can pass one of these.
Raise your hand if you
have a question, and
we'll get you a mic.
Welcome.
AUDIENCE: I teach at the local
community college at Foothill.
And I teach computer science.
So I was wondering if you had
any specific recommendations
that I could do to convince
the freshman to become
computer science majors
and transfer and get
a bachelor's degree?
ANGELA LAI: I do a lot of
college recruiting and I give
tech talks at universities.
I went into computer science
myself without--
you can't hear?
MEGAN SMITH: Maybe pull
the mic closer.
ANGELA LAI: The mic
actually works.
Is that better?
I went into computer science
without knowing anything about
it before going into
university.
And I always tell people the
story, I took the first class
in computer engineer--
I was going to do file
engineering.
And I went into computer
The first programming class
was programming a game.
And it was very,
very engaging.
Anna and I are programmers.
It's just this thing that can
hold your attention and
immense creativity.
And I think finding ways-- and
I have continued to find that
people feeling empowered, that
they can create something out
of nothing, make a game out of
it, and inject creativity of
it, seems to have a bend
particularly for women and for
female students.
And more of the creativity
part of it, rather than a
technical side of it, that is
inspirational, and is also
something that I think
all of us can agree.
In creating products at Google,
that's one of the
things that is most exciting.
Creating something out of
nothing in AdSense, what we're
doing with Google Wallet, with
play, and everything that
we're doing here,
[CELL PHONE RINGS]
except for the phone
that's ringing.
And I think instilling that
early into the program to let
people see what they
can really do,
it's something that--
[CELL PHONE RINGS]
MEGAN SMITH: Someone
really wants to--
ANGELA LAI: Someone really
wants to talk.
We'll turn it off.
Sorry.
So, yeah,
SUSAN WOJCICKI: It's
interesting.
I hadn't heard Angela
say that before.
But it's actually
the thing that--
I mean, I think computer science
has this vision of
being a more solitary
kind of--
running statistics
and numbers.
So I sort of fell into
it by accident too.
And I realized a lot of what
Angela just said of how
creative it actually was and the
ability to actually make
something and have that thing
be usable and for people to
see it all over the world.
And that's what I really
fell in love with.
And when I would describe that
to other people, it's not
always how computer science
is represented.
And so I think it's actually a
challenge of how do you make
it seem as like a creative,
building, and interacting and
working on teams as a much
more social experience.
I think people would see
it very differently.
GAYATRI RAJAN: And
I think also--
ANGELA LAI: Make sure
you have a mic.
MEGAN SMITH: Here, trade--
[INAUDIBLE] pull
that mic down.
GAYATRI RAJAN: I think it's also
important to illustrate
just the impact that
they can have.
I know they're young, and
they're probably not thinking
about that just yet, but I think
it's very important.
I think the kinds of things that
we do, and the number of
people-- it's not in the
hundreds or thousands.
It's in the millions.
You can build a bridge.
It's going to take many
years before a million
people cross it.
You can write a great app.
And you could get a million
downloads in a month.
So it's one of those--
it's here.
It's now.
And it's explosive.
So that the kind of impact that
they can have is much
more than they can expect to
have in some of these other
professions.
And I think they should get a
little bit of the sense of the
enormity of what they can do
with starting out with a
simple app or a game.
MEGAN SMITH: We created a
product called App Inventor,
mostly aimed at high school
kids, help them
put together apps.
We especially wanted to target
high school girls to pull them
into technology.
It's kind of scratch-like.
And now the MIT Media Lab
is running that project.
But just having people have
their hands on stuff--
I heard of a great class--
second grade class that was
taking Raspberry Pi, which is
a little computer that costs
about 25 pounds, doing scratch
programming.
And second graders have just
learned to read, so why
shouldn't they program?
So, pretty interesting idea,
and pull them straight in.
And the girls and the
boys were all in.
So having them have experiences,
I think, in
addition to--
I think exactly like applying
it to real amazing things.
Another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I work for a company aimed to
increase the number of female
founders in technology
start ups.
And one of the things we
always focus on is to
highlight like-minded
individuals in the female
world technology, who have
done things and we
can look up to them.
And the younger generation also
to have an iconic person
to look up and say OK, I
can get there as well.
What is Google doing?
This is the first year I see,
actually, women being more
involved and focusing on
women entrepreneurs and
technologists.
Where is your focus going moving
forward, because as you
mentioned, women are very
important in technology today?
MEGAN SMITH: Sure.
Do you guys want to
talk about it?
ANGELA LAI: You or me?
MEGAN SMITH: Because we
have a huge number of
programs that we run.
We work really closely--
we've so many different
programs, I'm not
gonna' think of them.
But the Anita Borg programs--
has everybody here been to the
Grace Hopper celebration?
If you haven't, you should go.
I think it's 3,000 computer
science women now, meeting in
the fall, that the Anita
Borg Institute
runs, which is great.
We work really closely
with them.
And we also try do a lot of
scholarship work with all
different underrepresented
people, with women, a lot of
recruiting, a lot of
those pieces--
Susan, you had a couple.
Were you going to
say something?
There's just a range of programs
that we're doing.
And also like this,
like showing up.
There's actually a question in
here about one of the internal
meetings we posted that's
about one of the Dory
questions or moderator asking
why the internal meeting only
had men talking.
It was a search quality
meeting.
I think they were talking
about spell check.
And actually typically, our
teams are more balanced.
And so I don't know why that
particular meeting--
and it actually is a good
example where someone's
checking us and saying hey,
you're putting a Google image
of an engineering meeting
out there.
Make sure that the women in the
team-- or choose a meeting
where there are women or
underrepresented women--
everybody's in the team in
the way we normally work.
So it's really important--
back to the media point--
what you project and
who you try to help.
Yeah.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I mean, I think,
the other thing I would
add is that I think it's not
just there's like one iconic
women, but that actually within
the organization,
everybody feels like there are
people in my group that are
like me, whatever
that group is.
And I think if you look across
our organization, we have--
because we've worked really hard
at it-- we have a good
women representation across
different groups, across
sales, across engineering,
across all areas.
But from a technical standpoint,
it definitely--
I mean, we have to work really
hard to get women computer
scientists and software
engineers into the program.
So we do have special recruiting
to try to increase
that group.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So my question would be do you
think it's worth hiring women
that are just interested
about technology and
then training them?
Do you have some program
like that?
MEGAN SMITH: We do some
programs like that.
I actually heard a really
interesting one by-- oh my
god, what's the name
of the company?
Social--
huge company.
There's a group in DC.
They're called-- it's
like Groupon.
Social?
AUDIENCE: Living Social.
MEGAN SMITH: Living
Social, thank you!
I don't know why I-- sorry,
Living Social!
Anyway, I met this amazing guy
from Living Social, and he's
been training people in DC in
general on computer science,
and has been making sure the
classes are actually
half-balanced, men and women,
just thinking of
very talented people.
And I think he's doing almost
like a three-month onboarding
and then pulling people in,
because they just need more
tech folks where they are.
I also heard an amazing thing
that Code Academy is 40%
women, which is great.
So definitely.
We also have a wonderful program
called BODL practicum,
which is taking underrepresented
minority top
talent, focusing-- getting--
pulling them
into computer science.
Because we need more people
from those backgrounds
in our field too.
So, definitely, we are part of
that, and we're also funding
some of the programs
like that.
And if people have ideas like
that, we want to hear more.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I mean,
I would also say--
Google as a representative tech
company-- we have many
jobs that are for people
who are not technical.
We have sales.
We have marketing.
We have operations.
We have lots and lots
of different areas.
And so anyone who has an
interest can enter through
multiple doors.
And if they choose, they
can go back and get
more technical skills.
But to be an engineer,
you need to have
the technical degree.
MEGAN SMITH: The
question here.
Grab your mic.
Go grab your mic.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: --or technical
experience.
MEGAN SMITH: Over here.
AUDIENCE: My question is in
regards to the statement that
was made a few moments ago
about it being a very
supportive culture at Google
and how great it is to have
someone in the room
who's like you.
So what about those of us who
are not fortunate enough to be
in that type of environment,
where there is not someone in
the room like us, what
recommendations or suggestions
do you have for women
in those situations?
MEGAN SMITH: Probably everybody
has been in that
position, where you're sort
of the only person--
you're the only woman.
Or you're the only person
from wherever.
Maybe talk a little bit about
strategies in that situation.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I mean,
I think it's a hard
situation to be in.
And I'll just say like two
things that come to mind.
I think first of all, I worked
at one organization before
Google where that maybe I felt
a little more isolated in.
But what I found is there were a
couple other women that were
there in that organization.
And we started to get together
on a regular basis.
We wound up having lunch
once a week or
once every two weeks.
And I found that actually even
though it was a small group,
by actually connecting, we were
able to form a pretty
strong bond.
And having some set of people
that I could connect to made a
really big difference in like
that they had shared
experiences about that
organization as well.
And then I say the second thing
too is that ultimately,
it's believing in what you're
doing and trying to get what
you think is the most important
thing to be done as
efficiently as possible and to
make sure that your work is
able to shine through.
And then if ultimately you feel
like you can't, for one
reason or another, to find
a place where you can be
recognized for the work
you're doing.
ANGELA LAI: It is definitely a
difficult to be the only one--
I'm the only woman in my
graduating class for many
years ago now.
And it was a small class.
It was about, I think, it was
only 50 or 60 engineers.
And I find myself in a lot of
design reviews and engineering
meetings, where I'm the only
woman in the room.
What I've found at Google, and
hopefully you can find this in
other parts of the culture,
a lot of men are also very
supportive.
Our last VP, Alan Eustace, is
a very great champion for
women in technology, as well
as my manager, Jeff Huber.
These are the senior
vice presidents
that will speak out.
And they will find a connection
by proxy in women
they support.
And I have found actually in
technology, the culture of
technology is very rationally
objective.
And I find a lot of men to be
actually great support for
things that we need to do it.
And by proxy of them thinking
about how they support their
family, how they support their
daughters, and the experience
in these proxy situations, it's
good conversations to try
to create the bond.
And also feeling confident to
not feel isolated is important
in finding other allies
that can help.
I think it is important.
MEGAN SMITH: You guys mentioned
Alan Eustace, he ran
engineering, much of
engineering, for many years
and leads a lot of search now.
He shared an office
with Anita Borg.
So he has high consciousness
about women's issues.
But he runs studies a lot--
I remember he did a study where
he was wondering whether
women were not--
in Google, you can nominate
yourself for promotion.
Or your manager might nominate
you for promotion.
And then you go through
a process of
very transparent culture.
And they were noticing that
women were not nominating
themselves as much as men.
So they ran a study to see are
women being promoted as much.
And it turned out that the
women that were being
promoted, the managers were then
taking care of nominating
women and making sure
that was happening.
But something where he wrote an
active email to the company
asking that women nominate
yourself and really
encouraging people.
And I think there is some
amount of maybe--
a friend of mine who won the
Anita Borg award, Mary Lou
Jepson, has synthetic hormones
from a pituitary tumor, and
she ended up taking testosterone
and found that
her confidence levels went up.
So I don't know, somebody
should study this.
She found other things too.
But watch the video
of her speech.
It's great.
But confidence-- and so she said
she really had a lot more
understanding of the men she was
managing and working with
from that experience, which
I thought was really an
extraordinary thing for
her and to hear that.
And so think a little bit about
confidence and maybe
there are gender differences
and maybe confidence or
feeling like the impostor
syndrome-- like if they only
find me out.
I don't know what I'm doing.
But you really do.
And having the confidence to put
yourself up for promotion,
in this case.
But also I think the more
important thing there--
and your point of connecting
to people-- was Alan also
stepping up to make sure there
was space for people in the
community and that they
were going to become
leaders in the same way.
It was really important.
So let's see.
We have a bunch of different
questions.
One of them actually is
one that's sort of a
controversy out there.
If any of you have read the
Anne-Marie Slaughter recent
article in The Atlantic entitled
"Why Women Still
Can't Have It All," regarding
the unsolved problem facing
highly successful women who
value time with their
families, what is
your reaction?
That'd be an interesting one to
talk about, because there
are trade offs and challenges
with balancing work and family
and relationships.
One extraordinary thing is that
both Anna and Susan have
four children under 12
or 12 and under?
Yeah?
So, just you guys are doing that
all the time at scale.
So I don't know if either
of you or any of
you guys have comments.
We have two boys, and
you know it's--
I think technology is a little
more forgiving than maybe
perhaps, say, Anne-Marie, who
was in the State Department, I
think, in a diplomatic role,
traveling quite frequently.
I remember once talking to
Sergey and giving a tour.
And he walked in and someone
said are people
here all the time?
And he's like oh yes.
They're here from very early
in the morning till
very late at night.
Just not the same people.
So we have this culture where
our founders from the
beginning were very open
to meritocracy.
Get the work done.
We don't care when
you're here.
And I don't know if you guys
have thoughts about that.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I mean, I
read the article too.
I don't know how many
of you have read it.
I mean, I think these
are very personal
choices that people make.
And I think if I look at the
choices that I have, I feel
like I've a lot more choices
than the generation--
that my mom's generation had.
I have the ability to have this
amazing job, running an
important part of Google's
business, and to have kids at
the same time.
And on the other hand, it's
not like there aren't
trade-offs.
It's not like there aren't some
compromises that I need
to make on both sides.
But I'm very fortunate
to live in this time.
And I feel like the message that
I think is important to
send to young girls is like
you have all these
opportunities.
You have choices.
Those choices are yours.
And there are trade-offs,
but there are choices.
And I believe that women--
that we have all these great
opportunities and that women
should choose-- if
they choose--
should take advantage of it.
GAYATRI RAJAN: An average
man or a woman
has 45 years of career--
spanning about 45 years.
Your children are going to be
with you 18 years maximum.
And my kids are already
out the door.
So I think that's something to
recognize that there will be
periods of your time where you
invest a little bit more in
work and other times where
you pull back and
invest in your family.
But recognizing that these
trade-offs will happen and
recognizing that it's not
going to be the same
trade-offs over your career
span, I think is very
important for young
women to realize.
It's a long-run game.
It's a marathon.
It's not a sprint.
When you have your first baby,
it's not a five-year horizon
that you're looking at in
investing for your career.
MEGAN SMITH: I just tell people
when they come back
from maternity leave,
right before--
I'm like you know, you won't
realize, but somehow you won't
actually get out the
door on time.
And you'll need to change
your shirt three times.
And you'll eventually
get here.
But remember, babies are
only less than a
year old for a year.
So maybe you don't work as much
that year, as crazy like
150% shipping and launching
and all that.
And maybe you're in balance
with your team, and maybe
you're not doing a
total start-up.
But then you do a start-up when
they're a different age,
so like that's a balance
for them.
ANNA PATTERSON: And also
pregnancy gives you a really
hard deadline.
ANGELA LAI: A schedule
that doesn't slip.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: I think the
other thing people forget,
that if you work really hard and
you have a good job, you
can hire people who
can help you.
And they will help you.
And you'll be able to help do
more to have more time,
because you'll have help.
MEGAN SMITH: Do you have women
in tech leaders that you guys
look up to?
Who and why?
ANGELA LAI: I look
up to Susan.
I worked with Susan
for a long time.
A lot of us have.
And I think that Adool it really
is one of the things
that-- we've always had
people to look up to.
And I typically sympathize
where you are in an
organization where you're not.
And I think that it
really does help.
And I don't know how to bring
the Google culture to the rest
of the world.
We work really hard at it.
We have also leaders like Alan
that I greatly admire as a
"woman leader" because he really
does speak out for
women a lot.
And I think as a community, we
all need to encourage our
leaders, also sometimes
a little bit shy
about speaking up.
But if you kick them,
they will do it.
And then I think it's us all
encouraging each other.
Just speak up for it, and I'll
champion for the NCWIT Sit
With Me campaign again to
just try to strike the
conversation.
It doesn't have to
be controversial.
be emotional.
It's just talking to them.
GAYATRI RAJAN: And I wanted
to say that--
ANGELA LAI: Here,
I'll give you--
GAYATRI RAJAN: I tend to look up
to people not when they've
done something spectacular,
but when they've
really given back.
And I will say this, without
embarrassing
Susan and even Angela--
because I've worked with both
of them-- is they found ways
to sponsor other people
in their org.
Some of them women, sometimes
men, but I think they've
invested and often not overtly,
it's often in ways
that are behind closed doors,
or it's that little nudge.
It's sponsoring you
in a meeting
when you're not present.
I think those are the kinds of
things they've done for the
women in the org.
And I know Angela has promoted
several women in her org.
Susan has.
And I'm a beneficiary of that.
So I think it's great that we
have women at Google who do
this for other women.
And I feel this is one thing
that every woman, regardless
of their level, this
is something we
can do for each other.
Women tend to--
there's research that's found
that when women tend to ask
for themselves, they are not
liked as much as when they ask
for others, which is probably
why you all think that you're
better at doing things on
behalf of others than
yourself, because it's clearly
a feedback loop there.
So if this is what we have to
deal with, then let's make the
most of it.
Let's try and help
other women.
Sponsor someone.
Say something nice about
someone when
they're not in the room.
Seed those thoughts in people.
And I think that's a way we
can bring each other up.
MEGAN SMITH: Terrific.
Yeah, in the back of the room.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I work here in
Silicon Valley, and frequently
am the only woman in a room or
the only woman in a form.
And I'm the community manager,
so spend a lot of time using
your products, Google
products.
And I wanted to thank you all
first for investing your time
and effort to have this event
here, the pre-event
dedicated to women.
And I wanted to make a comment
and kind of also ask you for
what your plans are in
the future, because I
was all amped up.
And it's like oh my
God, I quit--
I stopped work--
I had my last meeting.
3 o'clock, hop in the
car, get over here.
Check in at Google I/O. And
I'm ready to go here.
And they give me a t-shirt.
And it's size small--
Men's.
And I kind of thought maybe,
they didn't understand me,
because when they asked
me to register they
asked what my M-S--
Ms., right?
Female--
and I got this invite,
so Google
definitely knows I'm a woman.
Are you guys sure that those
maybe green or gray ones don't
come in women sizes?
No, this is the smallest
you get.
MEGAN SMITH: It's either
this or the XL.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: It's funny.
AUDIENCE: And then it's kind of
hard for-- and I'm not the
kind of woman who's intimidated,
as you can tell.
So that still makes
me feel unwelcome.
And I don't want to make
this a big issue or
confrontational thing.
Because we're all women
and we don't do that.
But the thing is I show up
and I want my shirt.
And I don't want to be told
that I can sleep in it.
So I would like to encourage
you, like, what are your plans
for next I/O?
How are you going to make women
who show up like me, and
they're like, oh my God,
I'm so excited.
And I don't care that I'm going
to be one, maybe, per
100 attendees, just one
woman, but I'm here.
How are you going to make it
even better next year?
And thank you again.
MEGAN SMITH: Sure.
Thank you very much.
You know, I love people
like you.
When we see great ideas then
we can execute on them.
So definitely let's work
on the t-shirts.
That would be good.
But I think, you know, Susan,
we had an event--
what's that?
AUDIENCE: Don't make
it pink yarn.
MEGAN SMITH: No,
definitely not.
I remember planning it out, we
had a rule, like, no rainbows.
Oh, I'm sorry.
That was the gay community
online in Web 1.0.
Yes, no pink.
Well, some pink for the
people who like pink.
But Susan, we had an event
at Susan's house.
We were lucky she hosted us and
you were talking about how
it's important to have
gatherings where we come
together, whether it was the
group when you had very few
women-- like find other women
in the company somewhere and
partner companies and just
build community.
And so our hope is that this
event is the beginning of
kicking that off and really
recognizing in a very public
way, as part of the I/O agenda,
that we really as an
industry need more women at
the table designing and
building everything.
And it's a really
important part--
Susan, you've got something.
SUSAN WOJCICKI: No, I was just
going to say I think it's
great feedback.
And we'll communicate it.
And next year, we'll have
women's t-shirts.
MEGAN SMITH: Yay.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]
MEGAN SMITH: Definitely.
So we mentioned Alan Eustace
because he's a big
supporter of women.
He mentioned--
I was on stage with him and
he said I went to the--
I think it was the Grace
Hopper conference.
And he said I know what it felt
like, because I got a
lipstick [INAUDIBLE].
So I think that's the opposite
experience of
what you just had.
MEGAN SMITH: That's
really good.
And you know, we talked about
Alan, but also credit to Larry
and Sergey, they've always been
really just open-minded
about talent inclusion, which
is the way I think of
diversity and just the way we
work, not only inventing
products but also how our
company should be.
And early on, I was not there
for this, but Marissa tells
the story of Larry getting yet
another guy's resume for
engineering across his
desk to improve.
And he just said OK, you get a
couple more of these, but if
there are no women in the queue,
there's no more hiring.
And so to take that kind of
leadership as the CEO at the
time was really a significant
move.
And it sets the tone.
They always wear the Women at
Google shirts and the Gaygler
shirts, whatever.
They're really sort of trying
to re-represent the company
back to us.
And so that's another, I guess,
action item, I'd say is
that ask your leaders
to team up with you.
And maybe if you need to give
them some of these examples,
but they're there.
So I think we're at time.
AUDIENCE: One question?
MEGAN SMITH: Oh, one
more question, OK.
AUDIENCE: It's a
quick question.
I'm a software engineer.
And I interviewed at Google.
And I was interviewed
by all men.
And I thought it would have
been advantageous for both
sides to have at least one
woman interview me.
And I was wondering what your
thoughts are on that.
ANNA PATTERSON: We
try really hard.
We used to have the rule, a hard
and fast rule that that
had to happen.
And as the company--
we have different times
where we have
very fast hiring velocity.
And so in one of those times,
it's relaxed a little bit.
But it's usually a hard
and fast rule.
MEGAN SMITH: It's important.
Important point.
I guess we'll close with
something exciting that I
learned recently.
Walter Isaacson, of course,
wrote the amazing book about
Steve Jobs' biography.
And I recently read that
he's working on a
biography of Ada Lovelace.
And he's doing this because he
became aware of her from his
daughter who's 21
and I think just
finishing in computer science.
And I had never heard of her
until I went to Silicon Valley
Comes to the UK.
And there's actually
a portrait of her
at 10 Downing Street.
We were lucky to be there for an
app-a-thon contest judging.
And there she was.
And for those who don't know
her, she was teamed up with
Babbage on the Babbage engine.
And she was really the
first person--
not woman, not man-- first
person to come up with the
idea of sort of symbolics,
and the idea of what is
programming.
It was a mechanical computer at
the time, but really, kind
of really the world's
first programmer
for symbolics thinker.
So pretty exciting to see kind
of our history begin to come
back at us in that way.
So I'm looking forward to
reading that book and learning
more and her inspiration
as we go forward.
So thank you, you guys, to
my fabulous colleagues.
And thanks to all of
you for being here.
AUDIENCE: [APPLAUSE]